[music]
>> A father
is cruel to be kind.
If my wife was seeing me, she would have
really thought of like it is going
beyond.
I gave the example of my wife because
she's a mirror. A moment has to be
mirror of man mashallah. She's
instrumental. After thanking Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala, I have to thank my
wife the support she has given me.
And she's always there as my musana.
Musana means a fortress against the
devil. And my level of dawah and my
level of iman and the level of striving
has increased after my marriage.
The intention
of mine was to show that if Allah helps
you, none can overcome you. If Allah
forsakes you, who's there that can help
you? So, let the believers put their
trust in Allah.
What you cannot dream, you can achieve.
Maybe you are getting this portion and
that this revision comes khalas. I'm
going to be
grilled, correct?
And I'll be grilled and maybe you know,
I'll have to leave the session.
Thoughts keep on coming, right?
People start thinking khalas now one
more sentence I can will say khalas,
that man will break.
You know there are people have cried in
this dawah training program.
I know
in the earlier dawah training programs.
My intention is whether you cry or not,
I want to make you die.
For the sake of Allah khalas.
Allah helps you, none can overcome you.
And why will not Allah help you?
If maybe you are answering wrong, you
would not. You were truthful to yourself
that you really strived and you did
spend 3 hours and you really did and you
did excellent job.
Now that will give an example to the
others that a person was not confident.
The person who said he could not do it,
he got 94% right.
And 94% is not
good.
It's not very good, it's excellent for
the first time.
94 towards the end
is not good, it is bad.
Not at the starting of the training.
So, the percentage keeps on changing
with time.
Raise your hand. Who would like to be
tested?
Okay, brother Yusuf.
Give the microphone to brother Yusuf.
Sorry.
I'll just come back to you. Yeah,
brother Atiq.
I know that
you had tough times in the last one
week.
Wait, before you answer, let me ask the
question then you answer. For you, the
question is different. How long will you
take to memorize the first 50 surahs
with meanings?
2 and 1/2 to 3 hours. Inshallah, you'll
do it.
>> Inshallah. Yeah. Make sure inshallah.
Yeah. Inshallah. Inshallah. Inshallah.
Jazakallah shukran. Yes, brother.
Surah number one, Fatiha. Surah number
Fatiha, the opening. Surah number two,
Baqarah, the cow or the heifer.
Excuse me.
I gave you an example
when I quote
Quran
Surah Al Imran, chapter number three,
verse 110. It's preferable to say surah
name
and the chapter
and the verse. Now follow as it's being
taught. Later on, once you become an
expert, then you change the order.
While training, follow exactly. Don't
even
try and make 1% change, please.
Once you reach expertise,
you can do opposite ulta in out and
we'll do that also. Up, down, in, right,
center. You get up from the sleep and
ask, you'll say. If I ask you,
brother Yusuf, if I wake you from the
middle of the sleep and ask you to
recite Surah Fatiha, will you be able to
do it? No.
If I wake you from the middle of the
sleep and ask you to recite Surah
Fatiha, will you be able to do it? Yes,
definitely.
Because I have it in my permanent
memory, I would be able to retrieve it.
Surah Fatiha, can you recite or not?
Yes, I can. Of course.
Without any effort in the middle of your
sleep also, you can. Why?
Because that is part of your permanent
memory.
You read salah every day.
Now you are really trained that from the
middle of your sleep, you get up. Oh,
I'm sleepy. What is Surah Furqan? 25.
Surah Rum, 30. 40, Ghafir. We'll do that
afterwards, okay?
Start.
Okay. Inshallah. Surah
chapter, meaning.
Surah Al Fatiha, chapter number one,
the opening.
Uh Surah Al Baqarah, chapter number two,
uh the heifer or the cow.
Surah Al uh Surah Al Surah Al Imran,
chapter number three, uh the family of
some family of
Al Imran. The family of Imran.
Surah Surah An Nisa, the chapter number
four, the women.
Surah uh Surah Al Ma'idah, the chapter
number five,
um
the the table spread.
Uh Surah Al An'am, chapter number six,
the cattle. Surah Al
Al A'raf,
the heights. The Surah Al A'raf, chapter
number uh seven, the heights. Surah Al
Anfal,
nine. The chapter number eight and that
is
uh the spoils of war.
Uh Surah Tawbah, chapter number nine and
that is repentance. Surah Yunus, chapter
number 10 and that
uh
uh Surah
Surah Surah Hud is chapter number 11 and
that is Prophet Hud.
Surah Yusuf is chapter number 12 and the
Prophet Yusuf alayhis salaam. Su Su
Surah Ra'd is chapter number 13 and it
is thunder. Surah number uh Surah
Ibrahim is chapter number 14 and it is
Prophet Ibrahim alayhis salatu was
salaam.
Uh Surah
Surah Hijr is chapter number 15 and that
is the rocky tract. Surah number 16, uh
Surah
uh
Surah Surah An Nahl is
chapter chapter number 16 and that is
bee.
Surah
uh Surah 16, Hijr. Uh
Nahl and that is bee.
Uh Surah Surah Surah Isra, chapter
number 17 and that is the night journey
or Banu Isra'il, which is known as which
is also known as the children of
Isra'il. And
Surah number 18 Surah Al Kahf, chapter
number 18, the cave. Surah uh Surah
Maryam, chapter number 19. Uh the the
story of Maryam alayhis salatu was
salaam.
Alayhis salatu was salaam. The Surah
number 20,
uh Surah Taha, chapter number 20,
uh
Taha, the Arabic two two Arabic letters.
Uh
chapter number 21, Anbiya.
Uh chapter number 21, Anbiya. Uh the
Surah Anbiya, chapter number 21, the
prophets.
Uh Surah
uh Hajj, chapter number 22, the
pilgrimage.
Surah
Al Mu'minun,
chapter number 23, the believers.
Surah
Nur, chapter number 24, the light.
uh
Surah Furqan, chapter number 25, the
criterion.
Masha Allah.
Takbir. Allahu Akbar. Takbir. Allahu
Akbar. Takbir. Allahu Akbar. Who can
improve his speed?
Who can improve?
Who can speak faster than him?
One
who can say faster than him? Raise your
hand. One, two, three, four, five. Okay.
Brother
Saboo.
No, time not time. Who's timing?
Take his time now.
Suratul Fatiha,
chapter number one, the opening.
Suratul Baqarah, chapter number two, the
cow.
Suratu Ali Imran, chapter number three,
the family of Ali Imran.
Surah number Suratu Nisa, the women.
That's chapter number four.
Surah Al Ma'idah, chapter number five.
That is the the repast.
Surah number six. That is That is An'am.
The An'am. That is chapter number six
and is known An'am is the
An'am is the cattle. Surah number seven.
That is Anfal Al A'raf, the height.
Surah number eight. That is Anfal.
That's the spoils of war. Surah number
nine, that is Taubah. Yeah, the
repentance. Sura number 10, that is
Yunus, that's the prophet Jonah. Sura
number
11, that is Hud, prophet Hud Alayhis
Salaam. Sura number 12, that is Yusuf,
prophet
Joseph.
Sura number
number 13, that is Ar-Ra'd, the thunder.
Sura number number
14, that is Ibrahim Alayhis Salaam. Sura
number
15, that is
Hijr, Hijr, that is the rocky tract.
Sura number 16, that is An-Nahl, the
bee. Sura number
17, that is the people of Israel or the
night journey. Sura number 18, that is
Al-Kahf, the cave. Sura number 19, that
is Mary, the Maryam.
Sura number 20, that is Ta-Ha, the two
Arabic words. Sura number 21, that is
the prophets, Anbiya. Sura number 22,
that is Hajj, the pilgrimage. Sura
number 23, that is the Mu'minun, the
believers. And Sura number 24, that is
An-Nur, the light. And Sura number 25,
that is Al-Furqan, the criteria.
Masha Allah, takbir.
Takbir.
Though your order
wasn't as told,
two minutes.
Two minutes, three seconds for first 25
sura with meanings.
You memorize in a particular way, always
say the name of the sura first,
then the chapter number, then the
meaning.
>> [music]
[music]